joining us now with reaction former
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
I know that in the time that you were
press secretary you tried to get along
he tried to be nice it seems nothing you
could do would ever appease that group
that was in that White House press corps
am i overstating it no I don't think so
at all look I think that a free press is
essential to a democracy but mistakes
like the ones that you're talking about
undermine the credibility and the trust
that the press has the problem is is
that though if you can't trust one story
or one one source in a story one of
these millions of unnamed anonymous
sources which stories do you believe
which which sources do you believe in
these stories I think that's the problem
is that you can't sort of pick and
choose one or the other which stories to
believe in which stories not to when you
see these mass amount of incorrect and
malicious attacks on the president and
conservative policies but there's a
bigger point here Sean which is that in
the Brian Ross story it moved markets
people lost money because of this
mistake and here's what I think the true
egregious nature of this is and what
Brian Ross did in the clip that you
played is something that happens all too
often they don't correct it they don't
apologize for it they quote update it
and that's that's a cop-out
when they're wrong they update their
story and just say we have additional
information when someone else makes a
mistake or add something to it they say
that they lied or misled them they hold
everybody else to one standard and
themselves to quite another Sean I even
think it's bigger because if you look
over the last year the whole the whole
Trump Russia collusion story after a
year has been debunked has not been
proven true but there is a Russia
collusion story that's Hillary now we
know in spite of a year of denials that
she and her campaign and her running the
DNC / Donna Brazile and their money they
paid fusion gps that hired michael
steele that paid russians for lies about
then candidate donald trump and it
spread like wildfire isn't that the same
as colluding to influence the american
people in the middle of an election with
Russian lies
well look I've been in Republican
politics now for over 25 years I've seen
this whether you're talking about
campaigns or on policy matters the
left-wing liberal narrative wins every
time I'm not asking you Smith sir they
see that we have Russia collusion
there's a real story she paid for that
phony salacious Russian propaganda that
got spread to influence Americans well
it's not just that you look at the
uranium one deal you looking for the
number of speeches that Bill Clinton
gave over and Russian got paid for I
mean there is a clear and concrete case
of what they did with respect to Russia
that is entirely ignored by the
mainstream media all right there's also
something else that's happening here you
have now if you're for those that follow
this show you're familiar with it and
that is we have discovered that Robert
Mahler's team what that James Comey put
the fix in with this other individual
that works for the FBI that we all
became known about last week and that
literally they're writing her
exoneration without doing the complete
investigation now does in the media get
a little suspicious about 33,000 deleted
emails in the bathroom of a mom-and-pop
shop that it did have classified top
secret special access program
information on it
miss handling information is a that type
of information as a felony destroying
that information as a felony and then
just for good measure she used bleach
bit and acid washed the hard drives and
then busted up all the devices that were
connected to that now the fact that that
exoneration Peter struck and James Comey
wrote the exoneration before they
investigated I don't know anybody in the
media that's doing their job it's what
they choose not to cover that also is
corrupt to me well and you also remember
that the DNC largely wouldn't wouldn't
allow the FBI's to even examine their
servers and no one seemed to have a
problem with that I mean there's a lot
about what happened last cycle that I
think has largely been swept under the
rug
and and none of the key questions are
actually being asked and I think it's
amazing how when you have concrete facts
on one side that should leave people to
want to get a deeper understanding of
what happened that's ignored and all of
this salacious you know hypothetical
ideas is what we spent we spend the time
focusing on I think our priorities are
or at least the media's priorities are
backwards and where the problems are
it's never been this bad my 30th year in
radio my 23rd year here at Fox it has
never ever ever been this bad
all right you have some big announcement
go ahead and hit us with it what is it
is it good I think it's good it's good
and I think it's largely driven off what
you're talking about right now I looked
back at the coverage of the campaign the
transition and the first six seven
months of this White House and realized
the stories that are being told are not
an accurate representation to transition
to the White House and then his first
six months in office and I'm going to
write a book today it'll come out in
February excuse me in the summer of 2018
if you go to my Twitter feed Sean slice
where people can sign up and keep track
of when it's going to be published and
get into inside information well I I've
decided that it is incumbent upon me to
set the record straight and give people
a real understanding of what happened
through each of those crucial points in
our history
this was probably one of the most
fascinating elections ever in that
regard considering all of the forces
that were against Donald Trump and all
the media that night that he won it was
like one big funeral look what again
there's a lot of stuff that ever that
those guys got wrong from the campaign
through the transition through the White
House I want to set the record straight
good for you all right Sean good to see
you thank you thanks